all right we are just a little over what
two months until the first primary and
the 2024 presidential election heating
up first the Iowa caucuses earlier
tonight Florida Governor Ronda santz he
did pick up a major endorsement in this
case from Iowa governor Kim Reynolds
just two months before that State's
caucus here's what she had to say
someone who most importantly can win and
that person is Ronda
santis
and it is why I am so proud to stand
here tonight and give him my full
support and endorsement for president of
the United States of
America and on top of that we are only
24 days away from our red State versus
Blue State State versus State debate uh
Governor DeSantis going up against
California governor Gavin Nome it's
right here on Fox moderated by yours
truly joining us now Florida Governor
Ronda Santos sir I maybe maybe it's a
selfishness oh you got a
crry yeah we we got some fired up we had
a good
event yeah we had a big event here in De
Mo and and and Kim Kim Reynolds is a
very beloved figure in Iowa because
she's done a great job so we've got a
lot of excitement a lot of people are
going to Ronda sis.com and helping us
out so thank you everybody for your
surge of
support Governor let's let's talk a
little bit about the horse race aspect
of it um one thing that I have picked up
from a lot of people as I talked to
people every day and I know it's the
nature of politics I know it's the
nature of primaries the one thing that
the constant theme I get back is is the
Republicans that I talk to Everyday
People they would rather the Republicans
all get along but that's not realistic
in a primary is
it well look I mean you know I spend
most of my time just just talking about
my my record of accomplishment uh my bio
and my vision for the future I mean that
ultimately is I think what this is all
about we see the country hit the skids
we see the decline across all these uh
indicators and the question is are we
just going to kind of shrug our
shoulders and accept the managed decline
of the country or are we going to
reverse the decline and have an American
Revival and that's just going to require
leadership you got to fight for people
you got to be able to deliver the wins
both politically and policy um you got
to be able to lead even when it's not
easy and so that's the message we have
and you know here in Iowa Sean you know
because you've covered this and I know
you've been here and done events a
caucus is is unlike a typical election I
mean these are people that are going to
go out in mid January where it's very
cold and they're going to have to go to
a site for for many hours uh to be able
to register their preference and so it's
really an organizational game we've now
visited 87 of 99 Iowa counties I'm the
only candidate that's going to visit all
99 Iowa counties which is a tradition
here the called the full grassly so
we're committed to doing that obviously
when you have somebody like Governor
Reynolds uh she's committed to
campaigning for us and and being very
active uh that is going to very help but
it's lining up the people that are going
to commit to caucus for you uh we've got
tens of thousands already that have done
that and we're going to work to get many
more let me ask you this question
historically elections are decided by
peace and prosperity uh elections often
usually come down especially when you're
up against an incumbent and a general
election are you better off than you
were four years ago can you have imagine
things would be this bad with three
years under Joe Biden because frankly I
cannot imagine
it actually I mean I was sounding the
alarm in 2020 I mean I worked very hard
in that general election to try to
defeat Biden on behalf of the
Republicans and um I just saw him as a
spent force uh I just didn't think he
had the the the capacity to even do the
job and I thought he would be
manipulated by far-left elements of the
Democrat Party and that's exactly what's
happened his weakness has invited huge
problems internationally uh his agenda
at home has been outright disastrous and
so you know we're now in a very
difficult situation as a country so many
of our wounds are
self-inflicted let me let me look at the
polls and let me ask you the question um
Donald Trump has had a pretty large lead
against all the other candidates um and
in many ways when you would think that
if a presidential candidate gets
indicted four times and arraigned four
times it seems to defy all conventional
political gravity that every time that
happens the poll numbers go up how do
you explain
that well look I think when that when
that Albin brag case came down I mean it
was just so transparently ridiculous you
to go back seven or eight years clearly
this would not have been brought uh for
non-political reasons and so I think
that he got a lot of sympathy you know
as a result of that in particular maybe
some of the others too but I think that
one really just showed just how
ridiculous quite frankly the justice
system has become when it's in the hands
of leftist politicians and leftist
activists but you know what we're seeing
here in Iowa is you know clearly former
presidents got a got a base of support
you also have a base of people who are
definitely looking elsewhere but then
the bulk of the people are considering
the former president but also
considering others some of them are
polling for him now some of them are not
but there is I think more much more
fluidity than what uh some of the
national media wants to to do and I
think the people on the ground here uh
see that there's a lot of people that
just have not made a final decision I
think the majority of Iowans will
probably make a final decision um as we
get into early January and I'd say the
same thing goes for the people of New
Hampshire let's talk about 24 days from
now um and this happened pretty
organically I was interviewing Gavin
Nome and I asked him in the middle of
that debate because you guys have kind
of been going back and forth against
each other I said well do you want to
debate uh Governor D santis he said
absolutely any place any time just give
me a day's notice that was his answer to
me I said okay uh will you debate him on
my show sure you can moderate it and you
know so now we have it scheduled for
November 30th in in the state of Georgia
um and and and it's supposed to be read
Blue State versus state do you get the
sense as many
are beginning to think that Democrats
are looking for a replacement now for
Joe
Biden 100% Sean Republicans need to be
prepared uh they are trying to push
Biden out when you see Obama flunkies
out there saying this that is not just
by that is by Design I mean that would
not be happening uh without there being
direction to that and so who would they
go with you know they've got Harris they
got but but Nome clearly is somebody
that's hovering there so I view it less
as about California versus Florida
because we could just look people are
leaving California and they're moving to
Florida you can look at the indicators
but I think what California represents
it's it's kind of the leftist petri dish
so whatever the Democrats have already
done in Washington California is kind of
like five years ahead of that so if you
did have a Biden second term I think
you'd get a lot of the same policy but
clearly if you ended up with like a Nome
they would have policies that would
really accelerate the decline of this
country whereas I think Florida
represents a model where we can reverse
the decline and have an American Revival
so yes there'll be differences that are
discussed between the two states but I
think the more important part of the
debate is how does that factor in to the
nation's future because look I've had a
lot of people flee California New York
Sean you know a lot of people in New
York who' fled here over the years
Illinois all this stuff and that's fine
and and we're we're proud of that but I
can't have every time these blue States
screw up that people feel like they have
to move to Florida I mean we really need
to make sure that the country gets fixed
uh so that people don't feel like they
have to leave all the time and as the
governor of Florida you know we've
benefited from some of it but uh
everyone should be able to live in Peace
and Freedom and security of the streets
and have have good education and that
used to be something that there wasn't
as much difference between States now
there's a radical diff radically
different approach if you live in an
urban area one of these blue States you
know there's massive crime uh if you're
going to some of these schol school
districts uh indoctrination in the
schools obviously the taxes and all that
the co authoritarianism was huge in
those States so it really is uh it
matters where you live now I'd like to
see all those blue states do better with
better leadership at the federal level I
don't see how we reconcile a lot of
these issues involving energy open
borders Sanctuary State high taxes low
taxes Law and Order versus defund
dismantle there's a lot there uh
Governor have fun in Iowa please tell
the great people of Iowa for the rest of
the country including me uh thank them
for all that they do to help all of us
uh they're amazing people in Iowa I look
forward to being there myself thank you
sir hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else